في مباراه ثمن النهائي من مونديال فرنسا
عام
1938 تعادل منتخبات كوبا ورومانيا بثلاثه
اهداف بثلاثه فلجات اللجنه المنظمه الى
اعاده المباراه بعد اربعه ايام طلب حارس
مرمى كوبا بنيتو كارباخاليس من مدربه ان
يشرك الحارس البديل اخوان ايرا لانه ملتزم
بالتعليق على المباراه لاذاعه كوبيه وهو
مكان حيث كربه خليج من المقصوره على فوز
كوبا بهدفين بهدف في مباراه ربع نهائي
طلبه خليص من المدرب اللعب امام السويد
بان الاذاعه كانت في عطله في يوم المباراه
فوافق المدرب وتكفر الحارس المعلق بحراسه
مرمى كوبا المرمى الذي استقبل الثمانيه
اهداف في ذلك اللقاء لتودع كوبا البطوله
بفضيحه مدويه لتكون اخر مشاركه لها في
المونديال ولتطلق الجماهير سؤالها
التاريخي لكربه خليف لماذا لم تبقى في
المقصوره